okay here we go so um let's play a
couple of blitz games yeah they have
been requests also for blitz cubed
saying and I will do that at some point
I think but currently um there's no
great game on so I'm going to play a
couple myself going here against bad
days and no i don't think i will play
one f4 there's a request for that but I
simply don't like it and I don't see
that I did not adjust the board design
correctly oh this does not fit well with
why could you see here okay no good got
the other layout again here we go yeah
bad days has high it's very high rated I
played in a min Samuel I think yes
Lawrence this is the first game and
hello hello back to Croatia yeah okay
I've got the moon felt i played this
rook see one line kionic see one they
all play but should be six nowadays the
Greenfeld guys are usually quite booked
up and it's a good move for fishery six
I don't really have anything great
against it okay not a huge fan of this
and sometimes I'm even get to get to be
in a worse position as I Lucas can i
play a burden defense say I'd rather
play the Berlin than one f4 to be honest
I did have some experience with that
I've played the Berlin like 10 years ago
but then I switch to
three a six and their old main lines of
the Roy also sometimes it was just a bit
more interesting it's a first game yep
yeah and don't please don't request the
Latvian and so I would put my thoughts
on the car one and a camera game
yesterday um yeah I think probably the
assessment right after the game by
karana was pretty much spot on it was
just an off day for Nakamura he'd simply
yeah sometimes you have those days where
nothing ever will will work and this was
maybe one of those days to be honest I
thought that that post game interview
was pretty remarkable know that kawana
really am yeah he sometimes has conveys
this expression of being a bit I don't
know I probably not doing this correctly
this is kind of assessment because of my
limited language skills but yes this
kind of somewhat kind of dry persona
sometimes that you think okay this is
somewhat I don't know dry a person or
whatever not sure if this is the right
word but it was very very as a very nice
warm interview I thought was pretty nice
okay what am I doing here 94 is a bit of
an annoyance he actually my development
is just just not great okay let's do it
like that I don't like it so much and no
I've never played the halloween gambar
this is the question and it's also this
is just just absolutely wrong it's a
totally wrong opening so no intention of
doing that I mean it's also so easy to
review that
I mean yeah this doesn't look right here
black is certainly in good shape him
that's funny opponent says he got some I
not sure if I should say that but he
says he is not one hundred percent in
inform Jan it will probably be alright
still I can't do this there's a question
about Peter Finley my book is too
advanced for an intermediate player and
this is probably depending a lot on what
you would call an intermediate player I
think rating off yeah it should be like
1800 plus I think maybe 1700 yeah
something something in that range if you
are lower rated than that let's say
seven hundred you don't need to worry
about opening books that much anyway the
question is can you sacrifice on c5 or
not it looks dangerous 95 TX rookie aids
looks very dangerous I mean I don't see
him winning at the moment but it's very
dangerous my idea is just 90 FOIA and
just grabbing second porn him if he
plays Knight f6 or so I think I should
be okay with Bishop e2 he's definitely
also okay
f5 interesting yeah let's let's develop
there's a question for a 1700 rated
player what chess puzzles or tactics
book to recommend it and what are the
water fair books for positional game um
it's not so easy to say I think for
tactics and nowadays as always the
option of practicing with with them with
sites like chess temple using tactics
trainers these kind of things um I'm not
sure that you that you definitely need a
book that's what I'm what I'm trying to
say for strategy I like that book by how
my groeten a chess strategy for the for
the club player I think this is a very
decent decent book to to learn strategy
or a pool strategy if five SSID I am
okay I think I'm going here let's see
nice till it still wants to go if I of
course if I broke you one this will
probably come down to some sometime
scramble and i'm currently ahead on the
clock
there are of course also books about
tactics but and don't really think I I
know something that i truly like there's
no one yeah porn power by Kumho this is
a really old book and I don't think it's
so relevant nowadays I think more modern
book would be would be more helpful
sadler's book is very nice on the Queens
gambit declined yeah there was a
question about a book on the Queens
gambit declined it's a bit old but still
pretty pretty good okay what to do here
96 is coming and they don't have Bishop
c4 okay I go d5 I want to be active here
don't want to sit around oh that I
didn't see I simply didn't see the move
time morning Jan
okay I've got some activity but it's not
enough he's got 13 seconds though and
you really played that so slowly the
whole game ma'am still a can I can try
something there on the 7th but I kv6
yeah I'm going to win this on time black
forfeit really i'm not saying I've got
compensation but this is not easy for
him to win really not um okay there is
no specific book on the black side of
the Queens gambit declined yeah there
are some options though I think if you
if you want to play the Queens gambit
declined with black you should mostly
check the night age five lines these are
most most relevant I think and the
Queens gambit declined exchange this is
what they play nowadays there are the
other relevant line is so it's with
Bishop f5 basically if you want to play
the black side of the Queens gambit
declined what um what you should do is
study two lines basically let's just do
that I know I'm not supposed to people
it's but a very specific question you
should play like this with black and if
they go III a good line is Bishop f5 it
seems very tough to break down it is not
super exciting because of this ending
but black seems to be all right down I
recently studied this together with a
student end
we didn't really get anywhere for white
um it's pretty solid the other thing
that should be included in the
repertoire is this variation with night
h5 here you force the trade of this
Bishop and a black will often play
Knight b6 Bishop e6 castles long this is
currently evaluating as okay for black I
would build up this repertoire around
those two lines probably with black that
endgame variation is debatable it's a
bit boring so you can maybe switch to
something else to get a bit more
interesting game ok next one PT Capri
and black and let's get rolling yes I
almost teach every day I mean I've got
today's but I don't have a student but
um it's often every day of the week a
little bit some days I'm busy as someone
less busy at CC 5 and f3 here and nights
646 is ok Oh as a tough question any
movie recommendations hmm not for recent
once I am really um what now i'm taking
this pawn i will definitely take the
spawn I didn't really have time recently
to to go to the movies so I'm not really
able to give you any recent
recommendation on recent recent movies I
didn't even get to watch Star Wars I was
kind of busy with preparing my move or
whatever and I couldn't really i didn't
really get this going and i really
wanted to see that
what Batman vs Superman now that's not
my kind of movie I really i'm not a huge
superhero movie fan I mean I mean I
don't really if people want to watch
that adds at school I think it's just
not it's not my kind of stuff I am I
also never I never read the comic books
so it's just not my kind of my cup of
tea
yeah he will definitely go with some
efforts about the only thing but i'll
try to put a night 26 is my idea mm-hmm
96 the night 34 no I didn't see the the
what was it the force awakens I did
manage simply did not manage okay what
to do here I would like to put the night
on default hmm what am I were looking
here you can just take here right oh
this is what I overlooked he can take p7
I didn't see that rook wander on the P
file Wow well that's no good I want a
stupid mistake that's really a very
stupid mistake totally unnecessary let's
go here for five
I that's a question of teaching chess to
people are kids especially beginners a
hex once play in tournaments um I'm not
sure I once heard that it's supposed to
hurt your own game if you teach lots of
GAD little kids or beginners I I cannot
really tell because I have not worked
with beginners much where students are
all fairly good players already yeah a
couple of students are industry Mia I
guess watch the stream um any other
question ok took a seven here so what
now 95 ok aight create eight gym let's
do that
blitz cutesy means I wouldn't play but I
would rather watch some games to that I
currently played on the SSC and do
commentary on them it's an alternative
and I really like doing that once in a
while but I also haven't played a game
today not a single game of chess oh I
don't mind I'm not two points down I
mean I'm one pawn down the a63 pawn I
mean if I don't blunder b7 my position
is just pretty much more or less winning
I think because white structure is a
mess and I'm a point up so it was a bit
a bit stupid how this how this turned
out but the a porn is not particularly
strong so I think I might be able to to
win it anyway so this one okay I'll take
here texty 6i what a stupid game now you
just blundered the the full d4 pawn for
absolutely nothing and yeah
ok so how to get the night clothes on
and this to f4 problem
you
check ya one thing if you teach two kids
or beginners is really it doesn't help
for your own chasm is all check yeah I
mean it also is a question if you are a
beginner if you really want to hi an
international master as your teacher I
mean it's it's it's not clear that you
need this kind of this kind of level
probably someone a bit less qualified is
also ok
hi Scott Brooks is seven unfortunately
at the end yeah there was a very stupid
game yeah I could have just just wanted
by not blundering the house
to say hi morning still not much that I
can do him wow I was that it was very
bad technical play I mean now it's not
even clear that I'm losing I'm probably
am still but I'm not sure about it check
check
if I was probably wrong Jen it's
probably still losing check in okay not
quite sure 15 seconds but I think here
with the age come on it should be even
easier to draw come on I know I don't
know that should be okay right I have no
time check wait for it sometime yeah
that was a time win anyway I I don't
mind it was a just a fighting game and
I'm most basically winning out of the
opening so like roughly here this is
this is just a lot better for like a me
I want to go to 2500 and I don't mind
odd time win so let's see um one of many
many comments gain started oh here mr.
cust oh yeah I've got a no score against
him and I know that I was winning in all
of the games with rigo Vasquez further
from Chile let's see what happens him
now can I go for give for this
check check yeah they all play that line
now it's it's kind of annoying it's
incorrect but it's not easy to play in
blitz I've had this on the board to
multiple times it's not easy not easy to
play and they all play it there
absolutely everybody how important it is
for chess to be well trained as a
question and I don't understand the
question do you mean physically well
trained or what is the precise thing
that you think about if you if your
question is if physical fitness is
important it is yeah quite quite a lot
actually okay so I'm happy not happy but
I don't mind to return the exchange if
he wants it which I doubt like 25 maybe
and just got Queenie five now heavens
yeah I screwed it up already I managed
to screw this up already this nonsense
opening
I came I can't go back but see that
wasn't the idea I'm not going to play
the Evans gambit today I've gone 24 17
I'm not playing well but my score is
good and I want to try to go form 2500
and I cannot do that with openings like
the evidence that I don't know how to
get rid of this nightie to take on e4
then
how can I get rid of this stuff somehow
can I return the exchange this is the
question
I don't know very tough yeah that
exchange sacrifice line is a real
problem in blitz chess it's it's rather
it's not a big deal in tournament chess
but in blitz this is so so annoying with
the dark squares being so weak okay
yeah annoying game but this this line is
a real problem I don't know what to do
against and lets it so difficult to play
okay is that an easy win for black maybe
it is he's got beef I've yeah this is
the thing it's got b5 coming the most
news I've played in a tournament game
that's a good question and easy to
answer this is 131 have played this game
yesterday 131 was it ended in a draw so
quite a long a quite a long game check
ok so how to do this now you will go
here and play b5 very likely i will go
to be oneness right here ok
check
time morning yeah I'm still in trouble
yeah of course but I don't think that he
played it well technically but I we'll
see we'll see
by doing 97 and the porn it's probably
still a win for him but no reason to
give up yet but still drive that is
losing but as I said I have played him a
couple of times and these games were
always tough it wasn't like he was just
winning easily
check am I losing here maybe I am but
now not anymore he will get there but I
just need to sacrifice the night it's
there a way to do that probably not
check and now I've got a draw but he
would be no time it's the same thing
against the sky okay this time I didn't
know play him usually I just outplay men
he wins on time and it's the draw of
course ya could have won this very very
easily but i miss the [ __ ] yeah that
could have happened anyway it's um it's
the same story every time against this
plan ok it was only I just lost 10
points them gain started ok let's see
what I can do it against Vicky John says
I am just a hound dogs by the way that
win was the signal for that loss I mean
okay let's see I'm playing them Zurich
variation and see what the vaquita is
doing I think you plays with g3 oh no
not this time
hmm don't remember 92 yeah it's again my
cell spiciest I've got quite a you stock
of that it's almost gone bajo bow wow
wow yippie yo yippie a long okay
oktoberfest be I don't know maybe they
really make it just for go by fast as
possible this is probably a question for
Bioshock right side would probably be
able to answer that here we go I got to
F for him yeah I like my position here
with them 911 that was nice of him that
he allowed that I'm still not positive
forever how I'm making any progress
there on the queenside maybe this is
this is not the right idea to open on
the queenside I don't know okay I think
I'm taking and I'm taking and now yeah
I'm even thinking about Queenie eight
Bishop b5 looks counterintuitive but
it's maybe a way to make some headway
it's got Nazi for them ok I'll go be
five so just double on the sefer maybe I
can bring my queen around to be 6 this
is a good idea the queen is better on b6
also looking at this rukon g1 currently
he cannot move his bishop the f1 bishop
h5 I could have taken that pawn now that
I think of it maybe I should have taken
the pawn yeah but as we know hindsight
is twenty-twenty I try to play maybe
just night back and before before it's
kind of serious now takes things and
will open up the position quite a bit
only after before I have to worry about
night see for this is something that
could be could be a problem takes 90 x
nights you form not so great if I just
double what happens if I just double up
I mean what is why it's supposed to do
here you cannot move any of his pieces
at the moment now that's good just
double our to life has to be a stronger
I didn't know and regular be okay I just
take this him check and 24 at the end of
this line then I think I win the porn
down the beaver pond
yeah he tries that some kind of
last-ditch hope counterplay but we'll
see about that even a 3 as good here but
I think I'll just take this for a three
check
yeah just a three should win next I'm a
three no probably not but let's go here
keep the pin on on the under night on
the night and I have a couple of ideas
before is the simple one yeah he cannot
move any of his pieces this is a good
thing night cannot move Bishop cannot
move root canal move okay Queen over to
h4 but i think i have this no way it
looks it too is actually winning right
check the night and go from a don't be
too wide brazilian yes there was a good
one that looked looked ok so next game
to 471
in Munich people drink the beer instead
of tea in the morning hmm I don't drink
beer in the morning and I don't drink G
in the morning game started oh its
better days again yeah yet this groom
felt and I don't want to gruene foul
again so probably we get some Queens
gambit stuff sloth no this one ok I
think yeah I try something new i
recently saw that this is an option but
i don't know the details about this it
was plated by some good players okay if
I take him
he doesn't have any good discoveries so
do I go III here on a mission I don't
know Bishop g5 95 might be an option so
I probably retreat voluntarily yeah I
played him in Samuels bad days I'm
pretty sure about that and he was a
tough opponent definitely was ok what to
do here I just wanted to play III Bishop
d3 but maybe I still want to I think of
are we developing the bishop I go here
to have a possible Bishop t6 if you go
see 5 my development is not great how do
you register for similar on the icrc
mules there are a couple of every every
month my next seem you will be on may
first I think and you have to be on the
server just right before right it will
be it there's a certain point of time
which when it starts and you have to be
around at that time and simply register
this particular moment yeah Bishop t6
this is the thing do I want to do that
I'm falling behind the development a lot
a lot
it was the idea so let's do it but it's
very cheeky oh wow
what the heck good play and I don't play
been tablet sessions know on the ICC
there's no particular reason they're
just that I tried the the symbiote and
it was really cool so I stuck with the
with the simulators displays ok I think
I'll start with this one ok another
tough position I hi to David in the end
the jet yeah I don't like my development
here I really don't there are a couple
of Morsi meals not just mine the others
John Fedorovich is also playing a
monthly event and there's also i'm not
sure God you jameelah hmm I'm sorry I'm
not completely sure about the name I
think it's called vol Jang it's the
handle he's also doing regularly assume
yours regularly okay rook could be one
nice play about bad days okay on before
I might have Bishop f4 this could be
something
Jim well played
Jeff I am like this
okay at least here he plays some
retreating
okay well if I can g3 next scan get
interesting can get interesting but now
he's okay him probably 94 was something
that would work intending 95 what is
taking a long time yeah this one that's
also possible of course so rookie
through yeah look she three who will go
nitey for but then i can take take on c4
and he's got night f5 hmm yeah it's
tough not to play that okay this one mmm
quite quite sensible quite sensible that
position does not look very good really
doesn't hmm
now I think he's he's probably probably
in an excellent shape him Nyjah voice it
doesn't feel right but I didn't see a
good move you can just take it you
didn't take it ok I think I would go
back it looks rough looks weird but what
can you do 97 probably yeah it's not
good it's just not a good position I
don't get get to his King at all here I
would need the Jeep on maybe g45 hey the
only hope is he takes a long time he
really does so x is there any way to get
this and then G foyer this is the last
hope and it's not a very young it's not
a very well founded hope and so g5
so what about this now f5 no doesn't
work this one I mean every move losers
so it's kind of you just have to hope
for the best Oh 192 the trends Knight f3
wow wow ly t 7 is almost made almost
well I just lost check check i can
probably take only five Mabel lose on
time now wow he really has a bad day wow
I was totally losing I was totally
losing what is contributing to a good
cause take CD to 2500
okay just 18 points 18 points short or
2,500 so I need I need some luck I need
a good opponent and I need some luck to
482 yep opponent please yep give me a
game please
yet to throw from that it's very time
started Peyton Manning and so this
wouldn't do it if I win this it doesn't
really help much a couple of points but
it wouldn't propel me to the desired
rating but let's see mr. Peyton Manning
age five just like that and okay what
funny funny way of playing the Benoni
without the bishop that's cool okay so
we cannot castle also how to do that you
can't think about f4 immediately but
it's AB it's a bit that's a bit crude
it's still probably right just that the
night on the two is entirely wrong it's
completely wrong them ok I'm going to
regroup it it takes a long while but and
it just it just so wrong only two
I want to go look a to you 185
yes he for maybe from 95 but let's still
a b5 and tried to have it immediately
very very tough he wants to go be five
yeah that's always an interesting issue
here do you I mean here I can completely
prevent it if I like with 94 okay let's
do it now okay it's not a complete
prevention it's got Queen to be six
check
I just blundered afore I just blundered
afore in one move and he doesn't take it
ok I think I have the sufficient luck in
this session and that I need I just
blended it in one move I did a position
where okay black was already on the
ropes you neither three is designed to
prevent to prevent the Queen to h4 so
here I could kick angle Queen d4 d5 or
you five immediately ok let's shoot e5 I
don't think there's a question if
drinking an alcoholic behalf reuse obeah
before a tournament order that is a
helpful way of preparation no I think it
says it's just University bad alcohol
just is not a good idea
yeah night if five I was thinking 24
should be strong but it's not not
totally clear okay so what now 94 is an
option but also nitey to just get the
pieces over 90 to 95 mm still quindi for
anyway
yeah I beer after tournament game
whatever just make some sense I guess
especially if you want ok b3 hmm ok I'm
just going to check this I don't believe
this this black should be able to or
disposition but it's a bit of a gamble
check check he's got the check he's got
to be 70 no I didn't see you we sir ah
shoot oh my ok
I thought Queen a seven heads through
maybe not not super clear this one okay
I cannot move the light and so probably
take this
yeah this is one of the more useless
kind of losses and I simply didn't see
anything here not good at all not good
at all I still have to fight i mean i've
won a couple of other weird positions
earlier bad thing is i don't really have
any active move so if i cannot move my
39 for example check it's got queen III
coming I 93 coming time morning check
anyway to get some kind of play going
night night here to e4 maybe for for
quincy three check
all right it doesn't really help
Clean Air Force probably winning for him
as are some other moves Who am I for the
game check hey unfortunately
unfortunately he said God 92 he didn't
see that but it helps him oh my Jeff
Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff come on check
wide load of rubbish game oh my oh my
that was bad yeah that was really really
bad mmm yeah i mean i blundered he
forward she cannot take and the other
verses i should never lose this position
it's it's strategically almost winning
for white just just some move and black
eye witnesses I just play he five and
he's get he gets steamrolled the way it
went also was winning for white but I
didn't I didn't finish it off simply and
this Bishop g6 was probably probably a
bit much even though it is it's
interesting I didn't seem Jan I didn't
see that route b7 move this is the thing
and then still thinks I'm better him
anyway let's play a new game
this is basically the end of the 2500
idea if you lose against a relatively
weak player you lose so many points ah
ok i was just playing too badly if you
play badly you cannot get to get to that
so i'm just i'm playing one more game
i'm down 22 for 58 boo yeah that was
like 20 points or something game started
and again cast oh yeah ok we will play I
will play the black side over something
here let's see let's see how the game
goes ok
yeah this isn't good at all but you
still have to have to do it right how is
this plate let me snap me let me
remember I cannot remember it d 5 maybe
also take here
mmm interesting i don't i don't really
know that line yeah why definitely has
some compensation for the porn I doubt
that he has more than that but it's it's
certainly playable for him
okay so what is the point trying to do
something against the beep on I can go
be six I don't like to do that but I
probably have to move my bishop later I
really would like to win a game against
this guy I mean he's never beaten me
just like in a normal game it was always
yeah me winning losing on time or
bruising on time in the drop position or
whatever he has never just one a normal
game no I'm a pawn up and I've got two
bishops what I don't have is a pawn
structure but this is probably one of
those games where he gets out played
again nie Dage for though I miss Knight
h4 ah shoot i should have to watch over
the edge foursquare okay it doesn't it
doesn't use this opportunity f5 no I
probably have to cover this
we're five takes rookie to take screen
at five and I don't I don't want this
kind of wild position him it's maybe
just good yeah this is a good good
position for I suppose the night yet
Queen g3 that was actually quite
interesting so let's see i'd like to go
age five and open this up let's see
double on the g file problem
John let's see
I don't see anything great that he can
do him to be honest
doesn't really have anything active I
think that you can do now try something
crazy I don't know g5 takes f five or so
it will probably find something better
because this isn't working at all huh no
moves I hope that's not some kind of
connection thing oh I cannot ping him at
the moon maybe it's disconnected that
would be unfortunate i would like to
just play this game and see what happens
I think I'm okay connection-wise yeah
white forfeits to disk yes I gotta win
due to disconnection and that's a bit
unfortunate my position is clearly
better but I've spoiled spoiled even
better positions and then this my ideas
to to increase the pressure here on both
of those pawns efore and 1g 4g phone or
they are both under fire and this is a
bit of a strong precept always annoys
him here yeah I'm clearly better but I
don't know what would have happened yeah
I can always always spoil ya know I
cannot play one more game I actually
have to do something here real urgently
so I hope you enjoyed it I've done my 15
minute overtime anyway and I've got a
good good rating it to 480 at the end
hope you enjoy it thanks for watching
and be back next week bye bye
you